how is Apple TV the only place you can
stream the history of trunks in English
no really it's true despite being the de
facto place to view and you know rights
holder of Dragon Ball the history of
trunk special is nowhere to be found on
Crunchyroll same with the other TV
special Bardock the father of Goku in
truth I'm sure this is the result of
some rights holder issue maybe a
contract with Apple TV that has yet to
lapse but that really only makes it more
frustrating to be honest imagine paying
hard earned money for a Crunchyroll
subscription only to find out you can't
watch those because well you see
contracts laws are stupid anime is
stupid get me out of here